[Music]
[Music]
william we're here we're back we're here
i'll call you unawares there you did i
was just fixing my cans as they call it
and i am how's it going uh yeah good how
are you yeah i'm good thanks yeah
what's been happening this week uh let
me think no oh i came to your house
yeah you thought you made me eggs we
taught the week before last about um
my fantastic
uh scrambled eggs method not really a
recipe just more of a method it's a
method domestic
and uh
you even brought your own eggs from own
eggs i had eggs brought some chives
i didn't want to get to the house
make it having thought about making
scrambled eggs and you go
well where are they oh yeah i mean
you're making scrambled eggs and i'm
supposed to be bringing the scrambled
eggs or the eggs yeah so i brought my
own eggs and some chives you made a loaf
of bread i had made two loafs of bread
time yeah but we didn't have the second
one well i had it during the next few
weeks tell us that you made two we only
had one that night but i just thought
i'd let you know i made two yeah yeah i
another delicious one we toasted some
bread yeah we did
i
you toasted it yeah i really whipped the
scrambled eggs up into a frenzy in a
deep saucepan whilst cooking it slowly
and what were the results absolutely
lovely dom i couldn't have asked for
anything more and i was hungry by the
time they came oh it took it takes i
would say double the amount of time that
you normally make your scrambled eggs
but you said at the end of eating him i
will never eat scrambled eggs in any
other way but that again yeah never in a
frying pan or was in a deep saucepan
absolutely with some butter i think oh
no was it butter oats butter in there it
was a cream as well it was a little dash
i would say butter and cream
it's quite decadent yeah well gordon
ramsay wants creme fresh in there and i
didn't think we'd deserve that no
but i'll tell you what tom it was
delicious wasn't it and i thanked you
for it i said thank you tom you did and
we put a little bit of giardina on top
just the just the sauce from the
jardinera was enough for me because it
was spicy spicy it's hot it's hot
but it was absolutely lovely and i thank
you for that you're more than welcome it
was my honor to serve you you very often
feeding me and it's nice to make a
change anyway she'll do a bit of
housekeeping
peeling the onion
how's keeping
how much fun are you
[Music]
and to me housekeeping now we've been
talking about the emergency bracelet
that saved me and my son's pants the
other day when we couldn't find a belt
to hold his pants up and i remembered i
had an emergency bracelet
didn't know who it was from yes we'd
lost the the letter and it worked a
treat here we go dom
i'll give you the story behind please
give me the
skinny billy and tom
i was very excited to hear you all talk
about the survival bracelets on my drive
home on tuesday and then later watch
billy recount the story of saving his
son's pants with the 550 cord i was
excited to make those for you guys
i have loved hearing and watching all
the podcasts youtube and to see your
friendship it's so much fun and y'all
she says you all
y'all that is
she is because she's from fort worth
texas exactly y'all really make a bad
day good and a good day
even better that sounds like something
billboards say i like to make those
bracelets because i worked overseas in
the middle east in iraq with the
military for six years
it was pretty easy to get hold of 550
cord and it was something to do when
there was nothing to do in an off day
consequently i would make them while
watching lauder rings trilogy on repeat
it was in constant rotation with a few
other trilogies i enjoy making them now
for friends and family as key chains and
bracelets i like making true survival
bracelets for those who would be in
survivalist situations as either of you
could be since you surf and any of dom's
world traveling adventures i mean you
travel around the world too yeah i do
yeah thank you
the bracelet is made out of one full
length six to eight feet of 550 cord
uncut there are some in posters and
poster then poster bracelets that
shortchange you and cut it in half so
you've only got two three or four foot
cords the other great thing about the
bracelets accent you guys they are extra
special because there is a waterproof
tinder fishing line and cotton thread
added to the core of the cord making it
an elite survival bracelet
all that said i would really love to
make billy's son a bracelet since he
surfs and seems quite the adventurer as
well as we bobby johnson and i'll let
you know that he's not an adventurer at
all no he's not
uh but er if you give me the sizes i'd
love to do that and anyway dom it came
from jennifer
fagan who's in fort worth texas and
jennifer i would like to say from me my
son and bobby johnson
thank you very much yes thank you we
finally got to the end of that mystery
thanks jennifer for getting in touch we
very much appreciate it hey wow we've
also had some voicemails let's let's
listen to one or two shall we johnny a
little bit
come on johnny
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
i believe um absolutely love the podcast
i could listen to you guys talk for
hours
um
so i work as a behavioral scientist and
i mostly focus on video games and as i'm
sure you are also aware of video games
often get a bad rap
but i was wondering seeing as you really
love playing league of legends and other
games as well
what are some of the
positive aspects that you've experienced
from playing games what are some of the
benefits that you've experienced
um from playing games yeah it's just
curious thanks dom
that sounds like
leak up legends
we've been playing quite a bit haven't
we we've had some epic moments on the
rift oh we've been loving it dom you got
an s minus and an s oh i got an s minus
an s and an a
and that's not like me no i'm gonna say
yes i'm season d's yeah i know
but not this week no not this week
you've done fantastically well
uh
nunu
e
congratulations thank you very much i
played with you during the high medinga
hijinx and you were insanely uh
fantastic and then also
uh nunu and the wollon although
and i wanted to actually just say it's
good to actually this on the podcast
nuno in the wollum is very famous for
rolling a massive snowball down lanes
towards people so and the snowball gets
bigger and bigger and then you can hit
into someone and it knocks them up in
the air and freezes them for a second
which you're brilliant at very adept
but also yeah i've seen nunu and the
wollump people
the little kid on top of yeah the wool
lump nunu
is also able to throw an individual i've
never seen you do that oh i do really
yeah because if you throw is it three or
forty three yes
i've never seen you throw a snowball
you've got a circle around you and if
you keep them within the circle while
you're throwing the snowballs by the
fourth one they freeze but it's hard to
keep them in the circle and then you get
well lumped debate them so is that why
it's hard is you throw one and they
start running and then you start running
you try to keep up with them and then
cancels them out once they leave the
sphere of uh of uh snowballness yeah
right so i'm not i'm not great i'm not
great at remembering all the buttons you
know it's not easy tom but positivity
what positives does playing video games
give you well i positively killed all of
the enemy team last night the whole lot
which i've not done before
i 1v5 them that's amazing yeah i've
never done that before so i was very
happy about that that is difficult we've
made some
lovely friends uh during the playing of
league of legends and had some
truly hilarious
moments i mean we've really fun where
all of us are cree stop laughing yeah we
did have our first fight ever that that
wasn't positive though should we talk we
shouldn't talk that was a negative thing
the first and only fight that billy and
i have had i mean we've had difference
of opinion like well i don't agree okay
i don't agree with that either and then
it's fine but an actual like
you shouldn't have done that and then i
can i don't care what you said you're
right i shouldn't have done that uh was
during league of legends um i'll tell
you what i like about it as a positive
thing i'm doing things in the house and
i'm doing paperwork and catching up with
this and that and oh
your life is hard
isn't it and then you go oh just go on
and play a game at league of legends and
it's just a bit of escapism yeah and
you'd be this little character doing a
thing rolling a snowball or and it's
just fun it's just a little bit of
escapism and fun as a crew you and i our
friend nigel our friend andrew our
friend jake a few other people natalie
that plays with us i think as a crew
we're quite positive yeah and we big
each other up a lot yeah so if someone
does something there's a lot of like oh
well done oh was pretty good good for
you type thing although the other thing
is that sometimes if nigel's had a beer
or two he can sometimes start to call
his names he gets quite yeah he doesn't
like to lose no one likes to lose but
nigel doesn't deal with it very well i
think it's because he tries to pretend
to his other friends he's good that he
doesn't play ah yeah
oh i'm not a nerd i don't i don't play
video games but he does play video games
he does play video games and he is a
nerd um he just i think nigel's in real
conflict with himself because you and i
like look every so often
a few times a week we play this game and
we're a bit nerdy about it but nigel
kind of goes oh you're playing your nerd
games then we're like yeah he's like
i'll be there in two minutes
so he's in deep deep conflict but i
think we pay each other a lot of
attention and give each other kind of
positive affirm reinforments
reinformants
during covid especially when we were all
isolated and locked down i found league
of legends and the league of legends
community to be a place where i could
have a little interaction with animals i
like fantasy as well so dipping into
a fantasy world of wizards and goblins
and witches and
cats on flying carpets that inspires me
uh
you know just walking around in my day
to think that i'm involved in that type
of game so yeah and just
to get a little bit better it's
something that a skill makes you kind of
feel like oh i did something even if
it's a video game i mean do you think
you're getting better at league of
legends i think you're digressing
only joking william i don't know if he
is voicemail no we've moved on john says
we've run out says there's no time for
that because we've got a fantastic guest
today i'll tell you what we got a
message here about tongue twisters we
might do it next week we've got a
message here about uh uh moving out we
might do that next week but like you
said unfortunately well fortunately i
should say
we've got a fantastic guest a lot of
people have been asking for this guest
oh wait before we do that i know hold on
but i did ask if any just to continue on
with our amazing regular segment of a
swear word in
each lord of the rings film um
we've got one here from nigel
and this isn't even uh
this isn't even in the film it's just
the title of the film right he suggested
lord of the
which i think is harsh i don't know if i
like that one uh
hey when mary and pepin this is from
sheamus sheamus martin who says when
mary and pippin go into saruman's
storeroom one of them should loudly
exclaim
holy [ __ ]
the same answer excuse me the same
answer here
from matia
spears stem i've probably got their name
wrong and also
beach
beachum x
frodo to gandalf keep your secrets then
here's what is what dumb and this is a
this is a merry one
where before uh pepin goes to minister
terrorists with gandalf mary
when i've looked in the volunteer you
say
why the [ __ ] do you always have to look
oh i like that one that caught me in my
chest
um
we've got a lot of comment we've got a
lot of comments from people when vigo or
aragorn i should say kicks the helmets
and breaks his feet he shouts [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
or something like that um
remember last week we had sean astin
said to oh sorry sam wise gamjee said to
gollum potatoes love that one and we
have our favorite yet we had al oh sorry
a delvo wrote back
with gollum answering what the [ __ ]
tater's precious
that was lovely all right well that puts
the bow in it we'll have more of those
next week but let's bring in our amazing
guests wait till you see this
you know what tom i've set myself some
goals this year oh one of them is a
workout more than i used to i'm enjoying
it
the weather's getting better i'm getting
in the garden i'm lifting weights and
i'll tell you what i used um
liquid iv
i really love it when i'm working out
you take one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water and it hydrates you
faster and more efficiently than just
water alone wow plus it's got great
flavors watermelon lemon and lime
strawberry i'll i love them all yeah one
stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of water
hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone it contains five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c with three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's also made with premium
ingredients and it's non-gmo free from
gluten dairy and soy and you will love
this dome
it's not just good for us but liquid iv
is on a mission to change the world
liquid iv has donated over 19 million
servings globally so you can feel good
when you support them that's fantastic
so grab liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com and use the code onion
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you use the code onion at
liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidive.com
promo code onion
dom using the internet without
expressvpn is like leaving your keys in
the car while you're running to the gas
station for a snack oh no most of the
time that's going to be okay but one day
you'll come out of the bathroom and your
laptop will be gone yeah not good i
always get a little freaked out when i'm
using an unencrypted network like in
cafes hotels airports because any hacker
on the same network can gain access to
my personal data like passwords or even
financial details and i've just found
out dom that it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone it's
just some cheap hardware that's all it's
needed yeah and our data is valuable
that's why hackers want it hackers can
make up to a thousand dollars per person
selling personal info on the dart web
that's why i use expressvpn it's easy to
use all i have to do is get the app and
click one button to be protected they
offer encrypted tunnel which creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between my
device and the internet making it so
hackers can't steal my sensitive data
it's super secure so i don't have to
worry about my information being stolen
and it works in all my devices yeah i
use it all the time every time i'm in
hotels every time i'm in airports i skip
over to my little app click on my
expressvpn and i'm super happy fantastic
john
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
onion that's e x p r e s s v p n
slash onion and you can get an extra
three months free expressvpn.com
slash onion
we are bringing in tolkien expert corey
olsen and i'll read this thing from
online here corey olson is the president
and founder of signum university an
innovative online university that
enables students to pursue their
passions without going broke
brilliant we want to talk about that for
sure known online as the tolkien
professor corey leads several weekly
tolkien discussions including exploring
exploring the lord rings a sentence by
sentence journey through tolkien's
classic story sentence by sentence so he
basically reads the book and does a
podcast about it i love it brilliant
well should we bring in corey we're
hoping to stump him aren't we well i've
got a lot of things to ask him we'll do
too let's do it
corey it's great to have you on the
friendship onion great to be here thanks
for having me i was running out of gas
on the way up here but i was listening
to your podcast so i didn't want to even
take a break to go into the garage and
get gas it's really it's incredibly
interesting you guys go so in-depth
but oh yeah and i know a little bit
about tolkien but you guys you know a
lot about the professor and his and the
world that he he invented
oh it is so much fun going over you know
i i've taught tolkien of course many
times i used to teach in college classes
and things and you know every time you
read it through every especially every
time you discuss it with students
they're always new things that you see
uh and so in the exploring the lord of
the rings discussions that we do every
week uh just kind of you know going
through the whole book sentence by
sentence man i i've probably read this
book 50 times but going through every
single week there's something that we
come across that i'm like have i even
read that before like has that has that
been there the whole time you know it's
it's just amazing it's it's so much fun
last night uh we had session number 218
just last night uh and we were talking
about the passage where boromir blows
his horn before they leave rivendell
and it was
fascinating fascinating like what i was
realizing last night that boromir is
actually like
uh kind of dissenting like he's he's
sort of um he's not on board like he's
showing that he is not on board like
everyone's gathered there right the
entire all of the elf population of
rivendell has been working for months on
operation secret mission right like
we're supposed to like the number one
most important thing is that sauron is
and his servants are supposed to not
know when we're setting off and what
we're doing what does boromir do he
blows his horn so that everybody can
hear it and he's like i always blow my
horn when i depart
and then he says like though after this
we may walk in shadows i will not go
forth as a thief in the night which is
cool like he's a rate kind of guy right
but like you've got like seriously the
elves are like face palming like secret
mission boromir secret mission i mean
it's a [ __ ]
i'm not on board yeah it's a little bit
of a dick move that's like a bunch of
guys that's like a party of people
getting together for a surprise birthday
party and saying right shh
close the curtains we'll turn the lights
off and when she comes in that's when
we'll save the surprise and as the
person parks at the driveway one guy
goes hey somebody
and then his excuse for that is i'm not
that kind of guy who does surprises
exactly yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i don't like to do that
kind of thing to people yeah no that's
it that that's boromir that's boring so
let's take it right back to the start
let's take it back we're going right
back
which is always something that me and
dom like to ask people is when did it
first come into your life when did you
first read either the hobbit or or a
load of the rings yeah
i was eight when i first read the hobbit
um so i had my i had my cousin handed me
a copy of the book i had just read the
chronicles of narnia by c.s lewis with
my parents
and my cousin had heard that i had i
loved the chronicles of narnia still do
and uh my cousin had heard that i really
liked it and so he said
if you like the chronicles of narnia
you'll like this and he handed me uh my
first copy of the hobbit which i still
have on a shelf next to me it's the uh
it's the cranky old uh paperback with
the purple emus on it which is pretty
cool because it has nothing at all to do
with the hobbit but
um
anyway so he handed me this copy of the
hobbit and said i think you'll like that
and i i read it and i got a copy of the
lord of the rings right after and and
i've been reading and rereading the
books ever since that's fantastic now in
these in these classes that you teach at
your university and we want to talk
about the university as well in general
but
does that compass encompass i should say
all of tolkien's work or does that kind
of zero in on the lord of the rings
specifically
so there are a bunch of different things
that we do on the one hand a lot like my
tuesday night class my exploring lord of
the rings discussion uh that's that's an
open discussion that's not like a credit
bearing class uh you know as part of our
official degree program um that's a
public program that we do for everybody
at any time and you know we distribute
that and everything um our courses
within the graduate degree program
cover uh cover lots of things we you
know we certainly cover all of tolkien's
works my broadcast there um i do a
couple different broadcasts so i do my
exploring the word of the rings
broadcast which is just on lord of the
rings and goodness knows that's plenty i
i said it was session number 218.
we're only at the like they're just
there we've not left rivendell yet
we've not had a driven dell yet and and
we've been it's five years we've now
been doing this every week and we've not
left rivendell yet so it's gonna be a
while um but i do other things so like
for instance i do uh my myth guard
academy series which is basically kind
of like an online book club where we go
a little faster we go chapter by chapter
instead of sentence by sentence and uh
there i've been going through for
instance the history of middle earth
series edited by christopher tolkien
which gives
all of the uh like the background
history all of the drafts that tolkien
wrote all the earlier unpublished things
that he wrote to sort of watch how
his stories and his ideas unfolded over
time really amazing stuff so
i've been kind of teaching my way on a
series through that and all this stuff
is available on our youtube page and i i
dived into something um that i thought
looked interesting cause i didn't know
what it was
the film film
and yes is this the idea that you guys
are working on making a silmarillion
film
yes it is this is the one where i was
totally interested because
i dived in in the middle of somewhere
but listening to you guys work it out as
a film
seemed incredibly interesting and it
made me think this is how you this is
how all films should be worked out
because you were going back and
you know polishing and so tell us about
that if you could quickly oh man it's
it's cool so this actually started uh
was inspired originally uh in the by the
process of the hobbit films when the
hobbit films were in production i
started uh a series that i called
riddles in the dark and what we did was
we kind of went through and we discussed
the hobbit and we were thinking about
like what are some of the challenges to
adapt the hobbit and so it began as a
kind of
discussion of the hobbit and a kind of
guessing game about like you know what
would you know peter jackson and company
actually do you know in the hobbit
movies and stuff um and then we actually
even had like um
you know so we'd have a question and we
had score sheets and everything to see
like who would uh you know who would
best predict what they would actually do
how they would handle this question for
instance one of our one of our questions
was are we going to see
uh are we gonna see
the severed head
uh of uh of of of of thrower you know
are we gonna see throws severed head uh
in the film um and i predicted that we
would which led to a really comical
moment the first time i saw the film and
azog holds up the head of thorin's
grandfather and everyone around me is
like ooh
and i like lost my head and i like i was
like yes
because i nailed it like i totally
predicted that we would see that
everyone's looking at me like what is
wrong with that guy
um but anyway so that's kind of how it
started off but once the hobbit films
were over we were like you know we just
we had so much fun thinking about
how like all the kinds of challenges
involved in doing an adaptation so we
said okay let's talk about the
silmarillion because
we felt very confident that christopher
tolkien would never sell the film rights
to the summer
so we're like okay this is a completely
theoretical adaptation right let's plan
this and so we planned it as a serial tv
show again you know uh like a 13
episodes in a season tv show um working
our way through the silmarillion uh from
cover to cover uh discussing all of the
you know and and it's it's grown into
this huge fan project we have people
people write scripts people uh draw you
know people do drawings of
of costuming and
we pick sets we pick locations um we
have uh somebody composing the score uh
for us it's really neat it's it's this
uh uh huge interactive project we're up
to the baron and luthien story now is
the season we're in the middle of right
now season six um and it's been so much
fun i feel like i have learned so much
it really forces you to engage with the
text in different ways as you're really
thinking about how do you take this
story and and make it come alive uh you
know in a way that's gonna be really
accessible uh to a visual audience you
know on uh on a tv show it's really
fascinating i gotta tell you it makes it
much easier like now when people are
asking me stories about the
uh about the
amazon show and stuff i'm like man you
know
of course they have to do they have to
make some of these kinds of changes like
you can't adapt you know you can't
make it work in a script if you don't
like for instance everyone you know one
thing that people are saying about the
amazon show is like oh they're going to
compress the timeline i'm like of course
you're going to compress the timeline
the timeline's 2500 years long what are
you going to have the human characters
dying of old age every 15 minutes
throughout the entire show like you
can't do that like of course you have to
compress it yeah but if you've never
thought it through that way right you
know if you've never tried it doesn't
work
and then and then corey just to very
quickly touch upon your university
program when i read your bio here
it says uh an innovative online
university that enables students to
pursue their passions without going
broke so you have found a way that they
can leave your university with a
qualification but not be tens of
thousands of dollars in debt that's a
fantastic thing so could you just
quickly tell us how you did that yeah
yeah well that was actually what so i
mean i started my podcast and i had a
whole bunch of people from my podcast
who wanted to take classes and stuff and
i was a tenured english professor at the
time and i was like well that sounds
cool um what inspired me actually to do
it actually to leave my 10-year job and
and found the university
was realizing that we could do that and
basically the secret's really simple
like it's not rocket science you just
lower the overhead right uh signum
university is a completely online
university we're a totally distributed
organization we have no campus right so
if you remove the cost of the entire
campus
from the calculation
it's a lot easier to keep your tuition
prices really low um because there are a
lot both directly like real estate costs
and building costs and building
maintenance and everything else but even
all of the indirect costs that are
associated with that um when you remove
a lot of those i mean so we end up
removing a huge percentage of the costs
uh and therefore we can afford to price
tuition the entire master's degree our
master's degree courses are like 650
bucks a class that's what we charge for
you know for for one class so you get
the whole degree for under eight
thousand dollars um
and you know we have a lot of people
take one class at a time you know do it
over the course of two three years um so
yeah you take like eight thousand
dollars spread it over two or three
years it's a totally manageable thing
you get a master's degree at the end and
uh and you know you don't go into debt
and you know we're in the middle of
working on we're developing an
undergraduate program where we you know
we want to be able to make this kind of
thing available uh to undergraduates as
well but the i have to say being a it
was hard being a college professor i
have to say especially being an english
professor because you know i'm here
talking to my senior english majors who
are graduating a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and with not
awesome job prospects you know um and uh
it was heartbreaking you know feeling
like
you know like i was complicit in this
system that was driving students into
into horrible debts so when the
opportunity presented itself to say you
know i think we can make a difference i
think we can do this a different way um
so signum has been from the beginning
dedicated to just kind of looking at new
models really investing in the online
model in ways that a lot of a lot of
schools don't a lot of schools kind of
use online technology but they're still
kind of they're they're still running
the old system they're still doing
things the old way and so we we sort of
have been occupying the online space
from the beginning saying how can we do
things differently how can we really
leverage this technology to do things
differently in a way that's going to
that's especially that's going to enable
us to charge people a whole lot less so
it's been it's been really rewarding
that's great well and just
just
let people know where they can find this
and how they can look for it and you
know
if you don't mind because it sounds
incredibly interesting and yeah
signumuniversity.org is our is our
website and our our program our master's
degree program uh is focused on
literature and languages um it again it
it grew organically out of my podcast so
we've always said we have
we have a tolkien studies program uh we
study a lot of fantasy science fiction
medieval literature uh that kind of
thing with the the the kind of niche
focus of our degree is very much uh
focused on the demands from our
community which is very heavily uh
slanted towards tolkien studies and
towards language studies as well mostly
because of tolkien but since he did so
much language stuff as well
growing up cereal was one of the best
parts of being a kid but dom you have to
give it up because it's full of sugar
and junk and you really shouldn't eat it
i hear you billy but we're all trying to
eat better like you said and healthy
breakfast doesn't have to be boring
magic spoon has amazing flavors that
you'll love but without all of the bad
stuff and it's amazing as a midnight
snack right before bedding let me give
you some facts dom go on zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb yeah and you can build your
own box available flavors to build your
very own custom bundle a cocoa fruity
frosted my favorite peanut butter
blueberry cinnamon cookies and creams
and maple waffle and there's also
limited edition flavors that are on a
rotating basis i recently tried their
honey graham an oatmeal cookie and let
me tell you my sweet tooth was satisfied
without the guilt dump go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and be sure to use our promo
code onion at checkout to save five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product it's
back with their 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
the refund your money no questions asked
so get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
i love squarespace i know you do too i
do tom from websites and online stores
to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business and the best thing
about it it's easy to use it is easy
because we're not very good we're not
we're not the best storm but i tell you
what i can even get my head around it
and it's got so many tools a lot of
stuff that i don't really understand
traffic overviews and unique visitors
and page view trends but you know we let
john deal with all that stuff yeah but i
find it easy and it's fun to use and
that's what i liked on with squarespace
members areas you can connect with your
audience and generate revenue through
gated
only content manager members send email
communications and leverage audience
insights all in one easy to use platform
which for us is helpful because we're
not that great navigating the worldwide
interweb zone exactly half of what you
said there i didn't quite get but anyway
all the best part is it's all your
content
you keep it all on the squarespace
platform and it's one click data
portability so head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com onion to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
but that's great because people who are
interested in that then as you say don't
have the debt get their degree but also
they know that they're being taught by
people who really know what they're
doing because there's a history of you
guys doing that it's not someone you've
never heard of you can look back at your
podcast for years
uh like i've been doing the last few
weeks and it's incredibly interesting
and there's so much knowledge there
that's a great thing well done yeah
that's fantastic that really is cory as
i'm sure you can imagine we've had a lot
of people writing into us i posted up
today on my
instagram account
i said
what's the one lord of the rings
question you've always wanted to ask an
expert i wondered if you'd be keen to
see if
you could answer some of these things so
i'll just
have a look here uh
let's go oh wow there's a lot well you
got one yeah i've got one
um
okay so this is a good place to start
is gandalf stronger than galadriel
came from magnus matatussies
now hold on tom as a
physically
emotionally spiritually or magically
they've not stipulated okay so let's
let's say generally generally generally
it's um
it's that would be closer i think than a
lot of people think one of the one of
the the the things that i find a lot of
tolkien
fans kind of think about they they tend
to classify so gandalf
is
a maya right i mean he's from valinor
he's like a sort of angelic being who's
you know come and taken on a body and
you know more closely related to the
balrog than anything else right is that
accurate yeah exactly which is amazing
yeah that's exactly right yeah
exactly right yeah like sauron and the
balrog and gandalf and sauron are all
kind of the same
category of creature essentially um
and uh
anyway so
and then you know so you've got these
you know the mayar you got the valar who
are at the top right though they're like
the you know the the the pantheon of
gods essentially of the world of middle
earth um again high order angelic beings
and you've got the lower order of
angelic beings of which gandalf and the
balrog and sauron are all examples and
then you've got the elves and and men
you know the incarnate beings in the
world um so a lot of times people kind
of assume well since gandalf and sauron
are on this whole other level right you
know above the elves and the you know
the mere mortals and everything they're
like you know angelic beings they must
be like orders of magnitude stronger you
know than any elf for any human but it's
not actually true there's a lot more
variety like that class of creature that
class of angelic creature in tolkien's
world
is really wide like sauron is is
enormously powerful right um
but there are a lot of creatures who are
really
minor um
people who are like creatures who are
like the spirits of uh
rivers and trees and things like that
like there are some of those that are
around as well um and sauron is like
massively massively stronger than they
are and some of the elves like galadriel
are really a big deal um so it's very
possible actually for you know so so
some people have the impression that
like no elf could possibly compete with
you know amaya you know that like
gandalf must be way way stronger than go
adria i think that it's way closer than
people would think i do suspect that
gandalf like
if it you know if it came to it
my susp
especially after
his resurrection like gandalf 2.0 when
he comes back as the white wizard
gandalf is definitely stronger than
godzilla at that point i would say right
beforehand
like it would be close it would be close
i mean if they got into a direct arm
wrestling match i suspect gandalf could
would probably win but galangio's a big
deal i mean she's a big deal so i think
it would be pretty close so i'd give a
slight edge to gandalf but i think it'd
be pretty close on the same sort of um
area of question here's a question from
billy boyd in scotland hello to you
um
what or who
within that sort of idea as tom bombadil
yeah
so tom bombadil is a fascinating
question and there are lots of different
ways to answer this question but he
basically it seems like he has to be
uh in that same kind of category of
creature right um
and uh even when elrond in the book
elrond talks about it right um you know
they at the council of elrond they
debate the question um because you know
it comes up briefly you may remember
they're like hey tom momma don't like
he he didn't even like he didn't turn
invisible when he put the ring on like
he doesn't seem to be bothered by the
ring at all maybe we should just bring
the ring back to him and let him keep it
and then it'd be safe right um and
elrond is like no you know ellen and
gandalf both say look if sauron were to
come himself right and try to take the
ring away from tom bombadil could tom
bombadil
fight off salah
no no he couldn't do it he couldn't do
it um
and uh but but anyway the way that they
talk about him it seems
pretty clear that they put him in that
category as well he is one of those
spiritual beings who's physically
manifested in the world um but he's he's
different tomorrow's different in every
way he's just a different kind of guy um
i mean anybody who sings all the time
and is constantly talking about the
color of his own clothing is a very yeah
in different kind of games so it's never
real it's never really um
you you don't know who he is from any of
the writing not exactly right not
exactly well especially since
he doesn't like have a normal story like
yeah he he describes in when he's
telling about his background he makes it
clear he's been there like they're in
that spot yeah
ever since before the elves like from
the from the create like from like the
world gets created tom bombing goes down
and says
this is it this is it this is my this is
my spot this is my joint i'm gonna live
here uh and he stays there for the
entirety of the history of the world so
far as we can tell so he doesn't have
like a normal story like nothing happens
to him except in as much as things
change around him like he remembers like
oh yeah there was this time when the
elves came through and they were here
for a while and that was kind of cool
and then the new minorians they had a
kingdom nearby and that was fun for a
while but then they left and you know
but he doesn't change and he doesn't
move and he doesn't do anything
i think that's why i like that character
so much he's great he's almost like uh i
think of him as like an indian guru or
something sitting in a cave and he's
just you know he's he knows everything
and he's quite happy like he could move
somewhere else except he does more
dancing yeah it does a lot more yeah
exactly and encourages a lot more
hobbits to take their clothes off quite
a bit which is interesting but like
obviously he didn't he didn't feature in
the movies but am i right in remembering
that in the book when the hobbits get to
the company of tom bombadil don't they
spend years with him
well it's see it's it's it's weird
because it's actually only a couple days
but there's this
there's this dilation of time right like
they
there are a couple places in the books
where
they stop for a while and they just they
kind of like lose track of time you know
and in the book they spend three
chapters basically in tom bombadil
yeah and and it's it's it's it's one of
the it's one of these examples of
no modern editor would ever publish the
lord of the rings today like if if if
j.r tolkien were to have submitted his
manuscript to an editor you know like to
a publishing house in you know 2020 or
you know 2021 he would like the editors
would rip it to shreds like batters
would never let a book like that get
published these days right and you think
about it right we've just established
the ring race the black riders right
they're the antagonists and frodo and
the hobbits they're running away and all
like we got to stay on the low down to
make sure the black riders don't catch
us so let's go through the forest okay
so they enter the forest
then
three chapters in which there's almost
no reference to the black riders at all
like we forget about the black riders
they're in this like totally different
space and what it's like it's like an
old-fashioned fairy tale right where you
enter into the woods and then you're in
a different time and place and you're
encountering strange creatures
and then they even the hobbits
themselves even report that kind of
experience when they get back to the
road before brie at the end at the end
of the three chapters they do visit tom
bombadil in his house and then they go
to the barrow downs and have the freaky
barrow white incident and then they run
naked on the grass as you were just
remembering that therapeutic nudity at
the end of the at the end of the barrow
white sequence and then they get back to
the main road and they're about to go
debris and when they get back to the
road they have this moment where they're
like whoa real world again it's like
they've you know passed through the
boundary of fairyland again and now
they're back in the real world oh yeah
black riders shoot we got to be careful
blackriders are looking for us
but for those three chapters we're in a
totally different world so you know i
like that
the the old forest with tom bombadil is
like that rivendell is kind of like that
in some ways
um
la florian especially um is like that
yeah i remember during principal
photography
pete
talking to us about some
friction between online communities
saying
it seems like tom bombadil is not going
to feature in these movies and why he's
such an important character and pete
talking to us guys on set saying look i
think tom bomber does a fantastic
character but unfortunately in terms of
trying to tell a filmic narrative we
simply can't sit around
for this time with this charismatic
character you know so i think he was
probably the biggest omission
in fellowship that we were all conscious
of a fan community yeah having an
opinion about oh yeah i think you're
right yeah could corrie couldn't you
know it's a glock
yeah i was just saying a really quick
story about that it was literally i i
have a flashbulb memory of this the very
first time i heard that the fellowship
of the ring movie was being made right
i literally the very first thing that
popped into my head as soon as somebody
said they're making fellowship of the
ring movie my very first thought was
well they're obviously going to cut tom
bombadil oh really that was literally
the very first thing i thought yeah for
exactly that reason like it was just so
obvious and i was like i was immediately
bracing myself i knew they would do it
i totally understood why they would have
to do it but i had to like i had my my
brief moment of grieving it was funny it
was like it was my very first reaction
i'm like okay
i'm not going to see tom bombadil and
that's going to be okay that's okay
that's like my very first reaction nice
well corey maybe we can use this
particular platform right now to put to
bed a question that gets asked to me
every time i do a q a every time billy
and i do a convention together or
separately
anytime i'm online
people in the street have asked me maybe
from now on if someone asked me i can
say you can refer to the corey olsen
episode of the french bunion where we
finally answer the question that was
asked to us here by
some movie guy named josh
why didn't they use the eagles to fly
tomorrow now billy and i have our own
answer but let's get let's give it the
expert answer
okay so there are
several different answers to this
one and the simplest and most obvious
answer to this is that that is a crappy
story who wants to read that story who
wants to watch that yeah there's no
drama right but we said that's a that's
a terrible story right so of course
that's not going to be how it's going to
happen i mean and by the way you can do
that to any story that's ever been
written right you can always say like
you're going to remove any drama from
any story by saying well like if like
some like all you need is to introduce
some kind of deus ex machina yeah
there's always a way to short it's a
short circuit of clubs and it's never a
good idea yeah so that's like one
simple answer right but as far as like
from within the world of middle earth
there are good reasons for this too and
that is that the eagles they're not a
taxi service they're not even just
animals
like you can't you can't like
you can like hire a winged uber like
it's not how it works
the eagles are not only free agents
they're they're kind of a big deal yeah
they're kind of a big deal
yeah i mean they're highly intelligent
and they're they're not even
beasts like they're not even animals
they're not even just birds they are
also like the balrog and gao and and
gandalf and sauron they are like angelic
beings manifested in a body the body
they choose is body of giant eagle
rather than body of uh you know old guy
with beard and really long eyebrows like
gandalf but um
uh it's always been one of my life
aspirations to have my eyebrows stick
out past the brim of my hat oh you'll
get it apparently
rocking billy's
10 years i'll tell you what i
and it's horse hair as you get older the
hair gets much thicker it's wonderful
you look forward to that cory yeah
well that's what i'm thinking i i you
know ever since i read that description
i think it's in the hobbit that his
eyebrows stick out beyond the rim of his
hat
life goal life goal right there but uh
anyway um
so they choose giant eagle form right
and they're there like they're they are
the they are some of the most direct
servants of the the king a high king of
arda of of of monwe the leader of the
valar the like pantheon of gods like
like you know basically kind of like the
zeus figure uh uh of
tolkien's uh uh valinorian uh pantheon
so
they have a job right
and if they choose to act if they choose
to help it's a big deal when they help
you that's why like the eagles are
coming is such a huge deal right when
they come in and rescue um folks at the
battle of five armies oh my goodness
it's a huge deal and there's no way you
could possibly expect you couldn't even
ask them to do that right right but they
did it and it's like whoa that's amazing
when they come in at the end um you know
there's the uh you know pippin gets his
wonder in the book pippin gets his
wonderful the eagles are coming moment
at the battle of the black gate yeah
right which is fantastic and um uh and
then of course we get them um you know
there are a couple other places where
they come in
but that those are the circumstances
like they choose when they come in and
when when when you know when guy here
rescues gandalf
that like he's doing gandalf a big favor
um and gandalf like gandalf won't even
ask he needs to get back to the shire
fast like so in the book you got to
remember gandalf has been locked up in
eisenguard for months and the whole time
he's like the ring wraiths are going to
the shire and like frodo is defenseless
they're going to hunt down frodo i'm
trapped here and there's nothing i can
do so he's like months day in and day
out been sitting there imagining like
they've probably gotten to the shire by
now frodo's totally dead already he's
desperate right and he gets rescued by
an eagle right
what does he do he doesn't say hey um
eagle uh
let me punch this into my uber to the
shire please can you just fly me
straight to bag end right now right he
doesn't do that because you don't do
that to eagles he's like um
where he does ask he kind of feels him
out he's like
how far would you in theory be willing
to take me right right and guy here says
many leagues but not to the ends of the
earth
right um and so he says okay just take
me to rohan so i can get a horse and
that's where he gets shadow facts and
takes shadow facts up into the north um
but again gandalf like who i hear the
wind lord the lord of the eagles is such
a big deal and he is like he is he is
um he is his own master he is serving
manway the the the high king of arda
you don't just work him into your plans
and say this is how we want to do things
so he imposes on him as little as
possible and just has him take him to
rohan and then he takes the horse from
there um so again that's an illustration
like it's
it is not it's a complete
misunderstanding like yeah it does seem
awful convenient to have a bunch of
giant eagles who could just fly you in
yeah but that is not the job of the
giant eagles and nobody not even gandalf
would you know pitch that to them right
i remember that is not that is not their
job i remember the the pippin at the
black gates uh during the movie because
all the writers of lord of rings the
film obviously were huge tolkien fans as
well and i remember philippa
philippa buoyance one of the writers
came on to set
so excited to tell me that i had the the
eagles are coming line that pippin's
gonna say that you know and and i
remember i got very excited just be just
picking up on her excitement because at
that point i didn't really get the how
important that line was you know
remember i said i was there at that
point when when she said you're going to
say the eagles are coming i said can
mary just be in the background going
welcome to the hotel california but it
was a completely different completely
different thing and it would never have
worked it wouldn't have worked well have
you got have you got another question
for corey i got hundreds of questions
come on let's see let's see if we can
we've not stomped you yet corey this is
great this is this is um
is there anything in any of the writing
that gives any sort of clue
of where the end waves are or what
happened to them
that was one of the questions that
tolkien always refused to answer really
when people asked him yeah when people
asked him he tended to say i don't know
i don't know now he did he did hint he
did hint that
the most likely answer is that they're
probably dead
um
it's
it's it's that that's the most likely
answer nobody wants to hear that it's
not but that's the most likely answer no
no it's not it's it's it's not the
happiest answer um the biggest hint that
we get and it is it does suggest that
they're probably dead is that uh is is
is in the song so tree beard in the book
sings this this song the ant and the ant
wife song where he kind of goes back and
forth me like the end sings and then the
end wife sings it's like this back and
forth um uh song that they have where
they're each talking about what they
like and and not paying attention to the
other one but at the end of the song um
they uh there's the two of them sing
together the aunt and the wife sing
together um that together like um
at the end
they will meet again and they will find
a land where both of their hearts can
rest but the song makes it pretty clear
that that's gonna happen it's basically
like after the end of the world
essentially it's like a post-apocalyptic
uh deal uh that that's gonna happen so
that they're probably that so
within the text the queerest evidence
that we have is that they're not gonna
be reunited until
um
until
after
the end of the world yeah
yeah i asked stephen colbert this
question i'm going to ask you too corey
if you had a chance to ask professor
tolkien a question what would you ask
him
i would
i would really like to have a
conversation with him about
the
the question the biggest question that
he never satisfactorily answered
and that is about the origin of orcs
where did orcs come from
um
there's an answer to this question in
the silmarillion the answer in the
published silmarillion is that uh they
were originally elves this is what peter
jackson and the team were working with
right in that speech that they gave to
sarman that they were originally elves
and they were captured and they were
like tortured and uh twisted and that's
where the orcs originally came from
but the thing is in tolkien's later
career after the lord of the rings was
written
he spent most of the rest of his life
basically
um not writing new stories but kind of
continuing to write in that world and
one of the main things that he did was
like um make it a lot more
fill in a lot of the gaps make it more
internally consistent there were a bunch
of things in a lot of the older stories
that he wrote which he was originally
writing as mythology basically and so
there were a lot of um
questions that just kind of never came a
lot of questions of internal consistency
that never really came up in his older
versions of his stories but he sat down
and he's like okay
this needs to work like i should be able
to write a story like the right of the
lord of the rings for the earlier stuff
as well for the silmarillion material as
well and if that's gonna happen it needs
to work like it needs to be consistent
so he he spent a lot of time trying to
iron things out
um and basically the orcs became a huge
theological problem like essentially the
problem is
if they're from elves originally
shouldn't they have free will
like later generations of orcs shouldn't
like baby orcs
have free will um and you can say that
like it's a nature and nurture thing
right like they're raised and they're
you know and but okay so doesn't that
mean then that
if you like raise an orc like get a baby
orc
and raise it like it could become a
happy friendly orc right um
uh and if so if that's the k so like
originally and i believe that this to be
true so this was definitely true
in his earlier silmarillion writings
like back in the 30s and stuff it's very
explicit orcs are not even
creatures they're like um constructs
right they're like
you know so they're not even they're not
even like animals they're just uh
they're made of like mud and slime and
hatred right so um
that that's why
in the books killing them is like fine
it's a good idea you never have any
qualms about killing orcs you do have
qualms about killing like the haradrim
right yeah um and that's where you get
that scene it's it's you know that scene
which uh uh which uh you guys did in the
movie where uh the horadrim guy dies
with faramir and sam and frodo standing
right there and they farm here the lines
are given to farm here in the movie um
it's sam's internal monologue in the
book but when they're looking at the
dead horadrim guy and saying was he
really evil in his heart you know um did
he would he rather have just gone home
you know
you know is that um those kinds of
questions are questions that you ask
about humans
um uh but not about in the books not
about orcs right you just kill orcs and
the more orcs you kill the happier you
are because they're basically just like
murder machines like that's what orcs
are they're not people they're they're
they're they're just like murder torture
machines and so the more of them you
decommission the better the world is
going to be right that's kind of the the
way orcs were conceived before
but if they're
if they're originally elves
then like do they have souls do they
have like could they repent can they get
better right and in which case it
totally changes the framework towards
them right so he was really divided
about this
in the publish so marilyn christopher
tolkien so talking had bunches of ideas
about this and christopher had to choose
one to put in the silmarillion so he
chose the elf version yeah but there are
lots of other versions they haven't
never really solved this problem
completely um so what i would the
question i would ask is that's the
question i would ask i'd say can we talk
about the origin of orcs just like
because i just like to like brainstorm
with him i'd love to hear yeah because
he changed his mind so many times i'd
love to just kind of talk through with
him
you know what was at stake with the kind
of the philosophical issues that were at
stake it came down ultimately to him to
like theology like evil can't create new
things so it can't be just like a new
species that was created by morgoth
because evil things can't do that but
free will evil dulce doesn't have the
the power to remove free will from a
creature that's been given free will um
you can enslave a person you can like
brainwash them but again you can't make
their babies yeah brainwashed before
birth you know so
in any way because he never solved this
problem the orcs are the biggest so
basically like make your mind up
professor tolkien you know what i mean i
think that's
come up with some ideas that are
constructed i can see why you would have
problems with that the way especially
the way
in the film aragorn like takes out
thousands of orcs like he doesn't care
well you have to have a bad guy that
sounds like you um that sounds like a
long afternoon in an oxford pub smoking
with quite a few paints that's just what
i would i that's it i would i would i
would i would line up a set of pints and
we'd have a long talk about i think
you'd be there until closing time to be
honest but i think that's a talk that i
would like to see though
here's a question that i've actually
seen quite quite a few times online
which is it which is an interesting one
to kind of throw around
uh
why is the ring so quick to corrupt
smeagol to the point of him relatively
quickly killing his brother but doesn't
seem to do the same to bilbo and frodo
yeah yeah
and the answer is it's all about the
attitude with which he began
right um
remember how gandalf emphasizes um he
plays on frodo's word remember frodo in
chapter two um when he's first hearing
about um uh gollum and the fact that you
know like who golem was and everything
and he he busts out and says it's a pity
bill i didn't stab the vile creature
when he had a chance
right when he when he hears because it's
through gollum that now sauron has
learned that frodo has the ring right so
he's like oh man if only bilbo had off
that guy when he had a chance then i
wouldn't be in this pickle right um and
uh and and gandalf pounces on that and
says pity it was pity that stayed his
hand pity and mercy not to strike
without need and then he adds
you can be sure that bilbo took so
little harm from the ring because he
began his ownership of it with pity
right so like and that's the difference
the difference was when
smeagol saw the ring he was already the
kind of person like he was already
making choices
of
i
i want things for myself i want to find
out secrets i want to find a lever that
i can use against other people right and
so the ring to him was immediately
a way i can do that better and get more
power for myself right so the ring had a
lot to work with with him even though he
was just this little hobbit guy
but that's the direction that his heart
was going already so that's why as soon
as he sees the ring he wants it right
um and he's immediately moved
it escalates to murder uh with uh with
diego yeah bilbo he has the ring he
doesn't really know what it is but when
he has the ring his first that that
crucial moment like that deciding moment
at the beginning
he has empathy for gollum he's looking
at gome and thinking like i need to save
my own life i need to kill this guy um
because if i don't kill him he's gonna
he's gonna kill me and then instead he
says
man
first of all this isn't a fair fight but
secondly
what a horrible life this thing is
leading right right down here in this
cave by itself and he imagines himself
in that position alone friendless
solitary in the darkness eating raw fish
and dead orcs for years yeah like like a
drug addict basically like
like the kind of classic stories that
you hear of someone you know sleeping in
an alleyway they've lost all contact
with their friends and family they're
penniless they're homeless because of
drugs i mean i know andy circus had
talked about playing gollum as a drug
addict there's a lot of correlations
right between those two stories yes
exactly he has he has so even though he
doesn't understand the ring's role in
that you know he doesn't necessarily
know to contextualize it in that way but
that's the kind of empathy exactly that
he has
uh for uh for gollum and so since
that was
who bilbo was and kind of the frame of
mind in which he begins his possession
of the ring the ring has a much longer
uphill battle with bilbo we see it make
some progress the conflict he has with
gandalf in chapter one of the fellowship
of the ring um we can see the hold that
the ring has on his heart it's really
hard for him to give it up yeah um
but
um but it it works much more quickly on
spiegel because smeagol's already
pointed in that direction um he's
wanting something that will give him
more power more leverage more
uh you know inside information um and so
the ring's able to work on that really
really quickly i love that moment in the
film where
you see
ian holmes was such an incredible actor
and you see
in that moment of him
standing up to gandalf where he's he's
convincing himself he kind of goes
you want it for yourself and he thinks
oh maybe i could tackle ganna for the
first time ever maybe this is somewhere
where i draw a line in the sand yeah and
i kind of say come on then put up your
dukes i'm willing to fight you for this
ring and then immediately gandalf owns
him and new zealand oh i'm sorry
brilliant yeah
well dom
we're we're midway through that chat
because corey has got a lot of facts and
a lot of things that we can learn about
extensive extensive knowledge so much in
fact we're gonna have to split it right
down the middle like a sandwich within a
cory sandwich exactly so the token
professor will see you again next week
on the friendship onion lovely stuff if
you've got any questions please send
them to the friendship onion at
cassmedia.com that's cast with a key yes
and if you're enjoying the podcast
please subscribe rate review you can
also leave comments for us on our
youtube channel and you should go and
check out our spotify playlist where we
put up all the songs that we listen to
on the show i think that's it is it well
if you want to show people around the
world that you're pretty cool then i
would get some merchandise oh yeah a
hoodie or a t-shirt or a pair of socks
and you get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
yes fantastic and also billy and i are
going to be coming to some conventions
in the next few months or so and if
you're wearing some friendship onion
podcast merchandise i'll take a picture
with you and i'll put it up on my
instagram page and if you want to see
the friendship onion live at any of
these places let us know and we'll try
and get it organized guys we'll see you
next week have a lovely week toodles to
you all bye bye
[Music]